j'ai beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise qui
évidemment ce show si devenir très
important de la sécurité de leurs
salariés et qui ont quelques difficultés
pour pouvoir répondre à toutes les
conditions de sécurité et d'hygiène
c'est assez difficile par exemple de
fournir des masques
c'est pour ça qu'on sommes ravis que la
région ait pu nous en donner pour donner
un ordre d'idée quand la région m'a
appelé pour me dire qu'elle me tenais 30
millions à ce qu'on a fait un bel à nos
adhérents est à la base de données c'est
ce qu'une entreprise dans le département
donc 5000 sur 90 l'entreprise si on
compte les auto-entrepreneurs en cinq
heures on est obligé de couper le
système on avait déjà plus de fournir le
monde
il ya effectivement de gros besoins au
gel de gros besoins au camp de gros
besoins en plexiglas pour ceux qui ont
un contact avec la clientèle
il ya toutes les entreprises du bâtiment
qui ont aussi des difficultés à pouvoir
s'organiser